[Music]
when you think of the great lakes
you may not expect this
these photographs of magnificent
towering waves weren't taken in the
pacific or the atlantic
they were taken at lake erie the thing
that i find amazes a lot of people that
aren't familiar with them is the sheer
size of them i've been with lots of
people that for the first time when
they're seeing them they're like really
this isn't an ocean
dave sanford is a professional
photographer from ontario canada
to do his work sanford waits for the
perfect weather conditions
heading out into fierce winds and ice
cold water to make his masterpieces
[Music]
lake erie is in the most southern part
of ontario it's the smallest of the
great lakes
as far as the depth goes it's the
shallowest by far
being a large lake but but relatively
shallow compared to the other great
lakes
creates unique wave conditions
the waves on lake erie tend to be
closer together with a lot more of the
violence on the white water on top
there's a lot of people that have lost
their lives on lake erie there's been
estimated somewhere over 8 000
shipwrecks on lake erie over the years
at her worst lake erie can be murderous
fact when she's murderous we call her a
widowmaker
[Music]
to be a nature photographer i think that
one of the number one things you have to
have is patience
the
first wave
photo that i posted from lake erie i
came home that night and i posted an
image and right away the number of
comments on it
it was crazy compared to what i normally
would get
and the number of
likes
[Music]
if i know i'm going in the water it
starts from like the moment i wake up in
the morning
there's a lot of mental preparation
there's an adrenaline rush too for sure
like i have no idea how things are going
to unfold
it's before the sun's even coming up and
you can see
the water in the distance and those
waves exploding
into the air and it's just such a cool
rush
the window of opportunity to photograph
the lakes for for me is
generally from maybe mid-october through
early december it's the best time of the
year when you still have that warm air
masses that are around this region and
then those cold air masses that are
coming from up north that give you these
really prime conditions
obviously weather changes and it's
constantly changing the biggest factor
is wind speed and wind direction a
southwest wind is the best and
minimal wind speeds i'm usually looking
at around 30 miles an hour at the bare
minimum at the high end of it you're
actually getting into category 1
hurricane level winds
over 70 miles an hour it's a crazy
mess of water and that's when you're
getting these waves that are upwards of
30 feet
the tough thing about lake waves is it's
not like ocean waves where you have sets
that come in and then there's a bit of a
lull lake waves are constantly pounding
you know you virtually have like two
seconds two and a half seconds between
each wave and where i'm at it's more
like
a giant washing machine it's not easy
you're kind of cold after a while too
that water is only around the 50 degree
mark there's days where there's ice in
the water and you're literally like what
am i doing like
water's very powerful it's very
deceiving and and you have to have great
respect for it you can get pulled under
and pulled out with a rip current it's
obviously a lot stronger than you are
you have to know your limitations and no
one to say when
[Music]
the waves that are generated from this
refraction off the pier
those are the waves that i'm
photographing that where you have
you know two masses of water two waves
that are moving in opposite directions
that are meeting and colliding and they
actually
they'll hit and they twist and they turn
and and
it's it's a phenomenal thing to see
it's just building this massive liquid
mountain that literally
lasts all of like a second if that you
know sometimes it's it's a fraction of
moment in time that's one of the things
that i love is the challenge of
capturing that moment
dave sanford's liquid mountain
photographs have appeared in several
online publications
including the washington post
he also sells prints on his website
i guess one of the things that i really
hope is that my photos can
allow people to
appreciate what they have as far as
nature goes and
learn to love it and
cherish it and embrace it and protect it
[Music]
you